joining us tonight former south carolina
governor and former u.s ambassador to
the united nations nikki haley
ambassador thanks for being here
thanks so much great to be with you well
we'll start with russia what you see on
the border there and how you think this
president this administration is
handling this moment obviously with the
german chancellor today
well it's an important day i mean i
think look none of this would be
happening if afghanistan wouldn't have
been the crisis that it was but what
you're seeing is
russia and all the dictators are seeing
an opportunity that this is the weakest
president that america's ever had and so
if they were ever going to invade
ukraine this is the time to do it i
think what russia is really trying to do
is get us to not allow ukraine into nato
and we have to remember that if you
start to give in to russia's threat
russia's threats there'll be just
another one behind it but the one thing
that makes the ukraine russia issue so
important is that china's watching this
because how this plays out will dictate
whether china thinks they can go ahead
with taiwan so all of these things
string together
iran is watching and biden's falling all
over himself to get into the iran deal
north korea is testing ballistic
missiles all of this
means that america needs to show
strength and needs to show deterrence
when it comes to any threats that are
coming our way or towards our allies
your successor
as ambassador to the united nations was
on over the weekend speaking about that
russia-china connection and what she
thinks it means take a listen
of course he's watching it we are
committed to protecting the security and
supporting the security of the people of
taiwan so if china is making efforts
toward uh toward taiwan because of what
they see happening in ukraine these are
two different types of situations the
ambassador's saying it's apples and
oranges you disagree
it's it's not two different types of
situations i saw china and russia
becoming closer and closer when i was
u.n ambassador i think you have to
realize that this is china watching what
russia is doing you haven't seen china
condemn russia you haven't seen china
call russia and tell them not to do
anything if anything they tried to stop
the meeting in the security council and
took the side of russia so this is
something that if you allow this to
happen with russia china is next and we
have to wake up we've got to realize
what's happening i mean we are dependent
on russian oil biden needs to be calling
out chancellor
schultz and saying look you can't have a
nato that's supposed to be you know
holding itself against russia when
you're totally dependent on on natural
gas you can't have chinese airplanes
flying over taiwan but at the same time
have biden sending millions of home
tests to americans when you flip it over
and it's made in china saying we all
need to wear n95 masks and they're made
in china we've got to wake up and
realize we are contributing to the
problem words don't mean anything it's
the actions that have to happen well
speaking of actions china's actions
against the uyghurs inside their own
country and then they have this moment
and the lighting of the torch
with a symbolic
uyghur
and a chinese athlete together
you reacted to that on twitter
you know i mean that athlete that was um
lighting the torch that's guilt that's
chinese guilt they put that athlete
front and center to try and say if we
show you something different then you
will forget the images of all of those
wiegers on their knees blindfolded that
are sexually abused tortured and that we
are seeing genocide right in front of
our very eyes this is them trying to
fool everyone we're not stupid you can
tell by the fact that americans are not
watching the olympics the fact that
sponsors are going to continue to think
they can make money and they can't
they're torturing people in front of our
face we promise never again we have to
stand by that we're going to watch the
rest of these games and obviously
comment about all of that as it goes on
i want to ask you one domestic political
question that is we heard from vice
president pence over the weekend about
first of all the 2020 election
republicans chris christie was on this
weekend as well saying the more
republicans talk about that
the worse it is politically here's vice
president pence
president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people and the american people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
under the constitution i had no right to
change the outcome of our election
and kamala harris will have no right to
overturn the election when we beat them
in 2024
so your thoughts on that and about the
focus on 2020
well you know i think look mike pence is
a good man he's an honest man i think he
did what he thought was right
on that day but i will always say i just
i'm not a fan of republicans going
against republicans because the only
ones that win when that happens are the
democrats in the media and we have to
keep our eyes on 2022 we've got to get
the majority back in the house we've got
to get it in the senate we've got a lot
of governor's races to win so
you know i mean look i think at the end
of the day i don't want to see
federalized elections i want them to
continue to be managed by the states we
have seen
fraud in elections time and time again
and when that happens is up to the
governors and the state legislatures to
make sure that we hold them to account
that's through voter id that's through
making sure that elections are decided
on election day that's making sure we
verify signatures well you're not
talking about it
that election was legitimate you just
talked talking about concerns big over
the long term
yeah when you have issues with elections
you go and you fix them that way you
know look do i think joe biden is the
legitimate president yes he's a bad one
at that but the idea is this is up to
the states to fix when it happens this
is up to the courts to fix but i think
that you know mike pence was saying what
he thought he needed to say he's a good
man he's an honest man and
you know i hope that at the end of the
day
president trump and mike pence can come
together and remember that we've got a
lot of republicans that need our help in
2022. ambassador governor thanks for the
time